JOHN MAYER: Thanks
very much, thank you
to Holly Manning for
helping to arrange this,
and for others of you here today
who have helped arrange it.
And I guess we just crossed
over into this afternoon,
so this afternoon
I'll be talking
about personal
intelligence, and I'll
start with one big
idea behind this idea.
If you're like me, you
encounter pretty much all
through your lives,
we encounter people
who advise us how to live.
Philosophers, religious
figures, teachers,
pundits, no matter where we've
come from around the world.
Mental health
professionals, and life
coaches-- I suppose those are
a little bit more Western.
But no matter where we
come from in the world,
there are people
who want to give us
advice about how
to live our lives.
And I wondered, what if there
were a common intelligence
that they used to understand
what they were saying?
A common logic that they drew
on to reason about people,
and to understand people.
Maybe to anticipate
they're using
some kind of common
intelligence that we
might call a personal
intelligence.
So I'd like to start with
elaborating a little bit more
about this theoretical basis
for a personal intelligence.
And I'll start with the idea
that we can't help but watch
people.
No matter who we are, no
matter how shy we are,
no matter how introverted
we are, by the way,
I'm an introvert.
Even though I'm
really introverted,
I can't help but watch people.
We can't help but wonder
about the people who we see.
For example, right now, I'm
so glad that you've come,
and I'd like to
welcome you here,
and I'm wondering
about all of you.
May I ask a couple
questions of you all?
I'm assuming you're pretty
much all from Google,
but how many people
here are from marketing?
Or advertising?
How many people are from
the engineering area?
OK, so I better talk about
personality in robots and stuff
like that, as part of the talk.
How many people are from sales?
OK.
And did I leave out any areas,
is there some area I missed?
AUDIENCE: Editorial.
JOHN MAYER: Editorial?
How many people
are from editorial?
OK.
Well great, welcome to
you all, and thank you
for telling me a little
bit about who you are.
But that's part of
understanding one another,
and I tell this to my
students at the University
of New Hampshire too, usually
when I'm starting a course.
They have already formed
an impression of me
from the first moment, even
from before I started talking.
In fact, the getting to
know you process really
begins finding out about
people's reputation sometimes
before you encounter them.
So we can't help but wonder
about the people who we see.
We watch people
wherever they are,
and even things that look like
people catch our attention.
So here are some sculptures by
Raymond Mason, or "Mah-sahn,"
and they just look like people,
but we can't help but look
at them.
So now if I might, I'd like to
go into some ancient history.
I'm going to go back
I think to 1988 or so.
Now, you may have seen
this gentleman here,
I know this gentleman was at
Google this past September.
This is Professor Peter
Salovey, a colleague of mine,
and now president
of Yale University.
And I understand he
was somewhere in Google
in New York, speaking.
But in 1998, sorry-- 1988, 1988.
Peter and I had traveled to a
conference in social psychology
called the Nag's
Head Conference,
and we were busy
working on a project
that we called Emotional
Intelligence, at the time.
And to continue my
theme of people reading,
you can already tell some
really important things
about my character, and
about Peter's character
I think, from this image.
First of all, here I am,
wearing shorts and white socks.
I'm the nerd, right?
And then Peter, we
didn't know at the time
why he was wearing long pants
at this hot, summer, North
Carolina location,
but we realize now
that he was aiming to
become president of Yale,
and that's why he was
wearing the long pants.
So if you can read
these clues, you
can figure out what happens.
But actually, the
serious lesson in that
is, we didn't know
why he was wearing
long pants at that
time, and there
are a lot of clues that we
just, we don't understand,
and it may have nothing
to do with the fact
that he ultimately
became president of Yale.
Now 1985, there were a
bunch of intelligences
that researchers were studying.
Human intelligences that
researchers were studying.
They included things
that I think many of you
have probably heard
of, you know what,
can I just check,
how many people
have heard of
verbal intelligence?
How many people have heard
of general intelligence?
And of spatial intelligence?
Performance or
mechanical intelligence?
They're sort of the same thing.
That one's a little bit
less familiar to you?
OK.
You don't have to know
what all these are,
and I'm not going to
go over all of these,
but I'm just mentioning
that in '85, these
were some of the intelligences
that were being discussed.
Social intelligence?
OK.
And then there were a
group of researchers
who were interested in
multiple intelligences as well.
That is the idea that,
well that there's
more than just
general intelligence.
So in 1990, there was
a grand organization
of accepted intelligences,
in which it kind of looks
like an organizational
chart, and you could think
of it as an organizational
chart, in which
general intelligence
is at the top,
and then there are these
broad, important, intelligences
underneath, which include
spatial reasoning,
and verbal comprehension.
Those are the ones that
you're most familiar with.
There were no what I would
refer to as newer intelligences,
or well, that's probably
not the right word.
But there was nothing like a
social intelligence in there,
and nobody had even heard
of emotional intelligence
at that time.
So that was the
approximate status
of the field when I introduced
our 1990 Theory of Emotional
Intelligence with Peter Salovey.
So in 1990, Peter Salovey
and I published this article
called "Emotional
Intelligence," and almost nobody
paid any attention to it.
But the idea was, that people
have the capacity to reason
about emotions, to reason about
things like anger, sadness,
happiness, and other
emotions, and could
use that to understand
one another.
As I said, we published
this paper, we described it,
and not many people paid
attention to it until 1995.
And in 1995, a New
York Times journalist
named Dan Goleman, wrote
a book which covered,
in part, our article.
That he also entitled
"Emotional Intelligence."
And his account received an
enormous amount of attention.
And people really
around the world
became very excited
and interested
in this idea of
emotional intelligence.
But a few odd things happened
in that journalistic account
of our concept of emotional
intelligence, one of which
was that the book made an
enormous number of claims
about emotional intelligence
that Peter and I had not made.
So there were claims
made around the book,
I'll say around
the book, I don't
want to single out any
particular journalist.
That emotional intelligence
predicted 80% of success
in life, for example.
Well the original claim
was 50%, maybe as high
as 50% of the success in life.
Then the claims rose higher,
80% of the success in life.
Now Peter and I had
never made any statements
as to any-- we had not
quantified anything
about how important
emotional intelligence was.
We just wanted to make
the point that we thought
it existed as a broad
human intelligence.
That's a real key to
understanding our humanity.
Because it meant that
instead of having
people who we might
label hopeless romantics,
or people who think
with their hearts,
that's an actual
reasoning was going on.
The more interesting
thing to me,
and incredibly
frustrating thing to me,
was that the concept of
emotional intelligence,
which was really
focused on the ability
to reason with and about
emotions, became generalized,
so that people said, and here I
will look at the actual quotes,
that emotional intelligence
involved graciousness,
super optimism, good networkers,
not too authoritarian, and then
another quote from
journalists, there's
an old fashioned word
for this body of skills
that emotional intelligence
represents, character.
Well emotional intelligence
was none of those things.
Emotional intelligence
involves the capacity
to reason with emotions.
And so it's quite possible that
you can be very pessimistic,
and be emotionally intelligent.
And why should we pick on-- I
think the thing that I found
disturbing, is why should
we pick on people who
are pessimistic, maybe they've
had a tough upbringing already,
and that says nothing about
their emotional intelligence.
Emotional intelligence
is reasoning.
At the same time, what
was fascinating about
it was people seemed
to need to broaden it.
They really seemed to want
to talk about the personality
qualities beyond emotions.
And I also resonated to that,
but in a more positive way.
I thought well, of course,
I'm interested in that too.
How do we think
about personalities?
But Peter and I both
knew this theory
of emotional intelligence,
it wasn't powerful enough
to hold all of those
personality characteristics.
And in fact, if you think about
reasoning about personality,
you should be able to reason
about personality no matter
what your personality is.
And you may not decide
to become a let me see,
a super optimist, or a gracious
person, or a good networker.
You may decide to
become something else
if you reason with
your personality.
So it didn't work.
That broadening of the concept
in the media, did not work.
It also didn't work from
a scientific standpoint,
for reasons that I will maybe
talk about a little bit later.
So there we were, we
had our hands full,
it was actually kind of cool
that the journalists got
it a little bit off, emotional
intelligence a little bit
off, because that gave
Peter and I a very
nice job for the next
five or six years,
we could travel all
around the world,
explaining what emotional
intelligence actually was.
And we had something fun
to say to people, I think,
and that was very enjoyable.
But meanwhile, what about
this personality issue?
I mean, could there be
a personal intelligence?
Well, there were
a lot of reasons
why it wasn't really possible
to just turn around and publish
something, develop a theory
of personal intelligence.
The first reason
was that in 1990,
and in 1995, when the
journalistic accounts came up,
many psychologists did not
believe that personality
was an important
system to begin with.
There was a movement in
psychology, generally speaking,
that people's behaviors were
all determined by the situation.
And indeed, if you look at
our behavior in this room
right now, it is determined
by the situation.
A number of you are sitting,
looking at me, listening to me,
and I'm walking around, speaking
fairly louder than I usually
speak.
If I did this at
home, my wife would
go, hey what are you doing?
Right?
Or if I did this on the street,
you would think I was crazy.
So the context,
situations really
do determine a lot
of how we behave
in one situation or another.
And so there was this
concept of situationism,
and there were
many psychologists
who said there's no
such thing as character.
Who believed there is no
A second troubling issue
was that nobody understood
personality very
well in 1990, 1995.
As a consequence really of this
belief that personality didn't
matter, and by the
way, I explain more
about the background of that,
it was a reasonable belief
to hold, as counter
intuitive as it is.
I explain more about
this in the book,
in the introductory
chapter, where
I'm talking about sort of
the context of all of this.
Given that belief that
personality wasn't important,
very few researchers wanted
to spend any time studying it.
And so there was very little
good contemporary information
about how personality operated.
Then I had some
personal reluctance
to propose the theory as well, I
was worried that it would seem,
kind of like, I don't know
if you know this expression,
I guess it's an old fashioned
expression, like navel gazing.
Lying around and
thinking about yourself,
being just really self-absorbed.
Would people think of
personal intelligence
as self absorption I wonder?
So these were some
of the impediments
to proposing a personal
intelligence back in the 1990s.
Recently, I've
suggested that there
was a tipping point in
the field of personality
psychology in around 2007.
And when I say 2007, I really
mean like, from 2000 to 2010.
There were huge
changes in the field.
There was an enormous
amount of data
that had been collected
about personality.
So that, we knew a lot more
about how traits related
to one another across people,
a lot more about how people set
goals, effectively
or ineffectively.
There was a consensus that
personality did matter,
situations matter yes, but
personality matters as well.
And so in the summer
of 2007, I was
working on a couple of different
papers, neither of them
were going very well,
and then suddenly
this idea of a personal
intelligence came back to me,
and I thought, well, you
know, now we know enough,
I'll write the theory
up now, and let's see
if personal intelligence
actually exists.
So in 2008, I published a paper
called "Personal Intelligence,"
I published it in
the same journal
that Peter and I had published
"Emotional Intelligence"
in earlier.
Peter and I discussed
this, but by this time
Peter was provost at Yale,
and he was a busy guy.
So I published the personal
intelligence paper,
and I suggested that
there were four areas
that we use to reason
about one another.
First, we pick up the
clues to one another
as we're looking at them.
So for example, you picked
up clues to who I am
and to my behavior as
you've been watching me.
Secondly, we form those clues
into models of one another's
personalities.
That was the second area.
Do we have a white
board here, would it
help to-- so clues to
people, the second area
was forming models
of what a person is
like, the third area is
guiding choices, both one's
own and others,
and the fourth area
is systematizing one's goals.
So at this point in the talk,
I have a very nice picture
of my colleagues David
Caruso, and Abigail Panter.
David Caruso and
I worked together
on developing the
Mayer-Salovey-Caruso Emotional
Intelligence Test, and
I contacted a professor
of what's called
psychometrics, which
is the study of mathematical
models of testing,
named Abigail Panter, at
the LL Thurstone laboratory
at the University
of North Carolina.
And I said, I've
got this new idea,
and I know you guys
are busy, but would you
be willing to take a little
bit of time, and work with me,
and see if we could
possibly develop
some measures in
this area, and see
if personal intelligence exists.
Now it may seem-- I don't
know how intuitively clear
this is, it may be very
clear, it may not be clear.
But to prove that an
intelligence exists,
that one of those
broad intelligences
that I was showing you earlier,
to prove that one of those
exist, you have to go
through certain stages
of empirical
research and testing.
And the first is that you
have to create problems
that people can solve,
or fail at solving.
So as I was writing the paper, I
started writing down test items
that I thought might be
difficult or easy for people
to answer.
So for example, let's say
I tell you about a woman,
and she prefers to
be around people more
than she prefers to be alone,
and she's also very talkative.
Now I'm going to ask
you, so she prefers
to be around people more
than she prefers to be alone,
and she's very talkative.
Now I'm going to
ask you, is she A,
anxiety prone and
fairly sensitive, or B,
full of energy and lively.
And I won't go through
any other alternatives,
we had other alternatives, but
I'll just stick with those two.
Anxiety prone and
sensitive versus
full of energy and lively.
So which would you say?
A, anxiety prone, or B,
lively and energetic.
B. OK.
So the answer there
was B. And the way
that we keyed the correct
answer, is we could-- by 2008,
we could go back to tables
of which traits go together
in people, that had been
developed over hundreds
of-- well tens of thousands
of people by that time.
And key the correct answers
to those questions that way.
Now that's one kind of question.
But here's another
kind of question,
see if I actually--
well, I'll just-- which
goal is more likely
to work for a person?
To become a better
employee at work,
or to always tell the
truth to other people?
A, all right.
All right, A, right?
Now, when you think
about it though,
and you're right,
again, A is the answer.
I didn't do what I might do
if I had my full overheads
and stuff like that, which is
to go around the room and poll
people.
But the first thing that
you notice when you do that,
is that there are differences.
Some people pick B for
the second question.
They think it's possible
to always tell the truth.
And for the first question,
a certain number of people
pick A. They think that people
who are talkative and basically
sociable are anxiety prone,
more apt to be anxiety prone
and sensitive.
And surely, there are people who
are outgoing and talkative who
are anxiety prone and sensitive.
It's just that there
are more people who
are lively and have high energy.
Now let me point out
another-- a key issue
with those two test items.
They are very different.
The reasoning is very different.
In the first question,
I'm asking you basically,
what have you noticed about
the people around you?
How can you describe
In the second question, which
asks about always telling
the truth, I'm
asking about what is
a plausible goal for
somebody to meet?
Those are two very
different areas.
We asked questions
in 16 different areas
in the first test
that we constructed.
And the idea was,
our hypothesis was,
if there is such a thing as
personal intelligence, then
people who are good at
any one of those 16 areas,
will be good at the other 15.
On the other hand, there may not
be such a broad intelligence,
and it could be that people
might be very good at noticing
traits, which social
traits go together,
or socio-emotional
traits go together.
And there might be
another group of people
who are really good at
solving questions about goals,
and there may not
be much relationship
between those two
kinds of people.
And at the same time, we
tracked verbal intelligence
as kind of a baseline.
So we knew that this was not
a jumbled intelligence effect
that we were getting.
Well I suppose I wouldn't be
speaking with you here today,
if it turned out that these
were all 16 different areas
of reasoning that were
unrelated to one another.
It did in fact turn out
that the 16 areas, people
who are good at
some of those areas,
were good at the
rest of the areas.
And what that allows
us to do, I think
is profound at several
different levels.
It allows us to,
enlarge our knowledge,
enlarge our sense of
human intelligences,
it allows us to understand
that there is information
about personality that
permeates our environments,
and it also, this is maybe more
scientifically of importance,
it allows us to specify
what the reasoning is.
Because although I presented
this to you rather simply,
like all 16 areas work
together, and that basically
is the story.
Since that time, we've been
building around those 16 areas
with new areas, and we find that
if we ask the questions in some
ways, people cannot answer them.
Or it doesn't relate to
personal intelligence,
but if we ask them in
other ways, it does.
Now what does this mean?
What are the implications
of this in our daily lives?
Well, early on in
conducting this research,
I started to look at
biographies of people,
to see if I could
locate individuals
who were particularly,
who exhibited particularly
high perception in this area.
And one of the
biographies I encountered
was that of
Katharine Graham, who
is the publisher of
the Washington Post.
And she has like five
pages in her memoir, where
she describes taking
over the Washington Post
from her husband, who tragically
had committed suicide-- who
had led the paper, but
tragically committed suicide.
And in this account, it's
so full of her models
of other people, her
understanding of herself
and her own reputation, that
it's really quite striking.
The first thing
that she says, was
that people tried to
buy the paper from her,
and that made sense,
because she had never
run a business before.
And so she's got that humility,
that self understanding,
she's never run a
business before,
she also has a very
good sense of her goal,
there was no way she was
going to sell the paper,
she said, not after what
her father and her husband
had put into it.
By which I mean their effort
and their creative abilities.
Then she said, she
started walking around
the halls of the
paper, which she owned,
because she inherited it
from her father and husband.
She started walking
around, she said,
I realized people looked at
me-- I realized a lot of people
didn't care I was there.
A lot of people looked at me
like an ignorant intruder,
and a few people were
interested in talking to me,
and maybe helping me out.
And by the way, I'm
working no slides here,
no notes here, so this is
the gist of my recollection,
but it's pretty close, I think.
Well I read that,
and I thought, that's
probably-- having
been an employee,
and watched new bosses
come in, that probably
is the way people
were looking at her.
And then she did something,
like several paragraphs
later, which again
amazed me, she said,
I started taking
over, and things
started to go well
for me, but I didn't
feel like I was living up
to what my husband had done
before me, and neither
did a lot of other people.
And then, and this gets to
this forming models part.
So she was getting clues from
how people reacted to her,
and the clues were not
necessarily very subtle,
but some people miss even clues
to how people are responding.
But in this forming
models point,
she said, I realized I
had idolized my husband,
I had idolized his leadership,
and of course when somebody
dies, we say all the wonderful
positive things about them,
so that's the tendency
to idolize rises.
And she said, I realized
I could not become him,
and I couldn't reach that level
of becoming an idol myself.
I had to start over again
and find my own style.
And that's great, that's
both forming a model,
understanding that her
original model of her husband's
leadership might have
been exaggerated,
and it's also guiding a choice.
As a consequence, because I
cannot become what my husband
was, I have to start
over again with who I am,
and how I can lead.
So that's an example, I think,
of how this capacity to reason
that we're able to now
isolate in the laboratory,
and track using this test of
personal intelligence, which
is called creative,
really creatively,
the Test of Personal
Intelligence, or the TOPI,
we can see that in the
laboratory on the one hand,
and then we can see
its consequences
for a person's life, in
situations such as biographies.
If I might draw on
a second example.
Yesterday I was at
the Rubin Museum,
which I think is just several
blocks from here, yes?
And I had the privilege
of interviewing a poker
player named Vanessa
Selbst, who's
one of the leading poker
players in the world.
And as I interviewed her, I was
interested in kind of applying
some personal intelligence
ideas to how she thought
about her card game, I
should say, by the way,
I know very little about poker.
I was introduced
as knowing nothing
about poker, which isn't
too far from the truth.
But I do know this
much about poker,
it involves a variety of
different understandings
at the same time.
So there is for example, this
statistical understanding
of the card game.
And the statistical
understanding,
just to go back to that
diagram of broad intelligences
that we were talking about.
That could come from either
of two different kinds
of intelligences.
One is the verbal propositional.
Because some mathematicians,
the engineers here,
because I know there are
a lot of engineers here--
a number of you probably work
with formulae a great deal.
So you're masters at
manipulating formulae, using
formulate, and so forth.
But there are some
of you who work
with a different intelligence
to solve math problems, which
is spatial intelligence.
So you imagine,
if you are drawing
on spatial intelligence, or
some of you draw on both,
in fact, all of you
draw on both, I'm sure.
those of you who lean more
towards spatial intelligence,
may manipulate geometrical
objects in your minds,
and get solutions that way.
In fact, I had a
professor at Stanford,
where I was a post doc,
and he would come up
with solutions to
problems completely
using spatial reasoning,
it seemed like.
And then he would turn to
his graduate students, who
weren't entirely
happy about this,
and say, OK, here's the answer,
can you please go prove it.
And then they would
have to go, and go line
by line through the verbal
propositional proofs
to demonstrate what
he was imagining
in his head, which was great.
I mean it did work out for both.
But anyway, Vanessa is doing
that statistical calculation
as she is looking
at that poker game.
She's calculating the
likelihood of different cards
that people are
holding, and that
doesn't have much to do
with personal intelligence.
She's also calculating
different wagers,
the value of different
wagers she's making.
But here's where the personal
intelligence comes in.
She is forming models
of people, and what's
interesting about her models,
is they are very poker focused.
So she doesn't
really care, I don't
think she would
mind my saying this,
and this is my
characterization of it,
but there's a lot of
things for example,
if you're trying to form
a model of your boss,
you want to know a
lot about your boss.
She doesn't want to know
that much about the people
she's playing against,
she's got, I don't know,
how many people sit
at a poker table,
I didn't ask her that
question, do any of you know?
Sorry?
Three?
Three I heard, more?
Up to nine.
OK.
So some weren't like, she's
got let's say, five people
around her.
She's got to form a model of
each of those five people,
and as she said, I
hope I'm not giving it,
I don't think I'm giving away
any deep, dark secrets here,
she said, if you're
a beginner at poker,
one of the mistakes beginners
make is that they talk.
And she said, you should
never talk in my presence
if you're a beginner because,
and she gave an example.
I can't wait, I just saved
my money for two years
to join this tournament, and
I'm really looking forward
to playing with you all.
She says, OK.
So my model of that person
is now incremented, you know,
n plus 1, for the engineers.
I know that that person is
very unlikely to bluff early
in the game, because if
they were discovered,
they would lose all
their money, and they
would lose their part
in the tournament.
So I know that if that
person starts wagering,
they've got a good hand.
OK.
That's her poker limited model.
She also looks at
socioeconomic status
of the people who
she's looking at.
So if they seem wealthy,
she evaluates their behavior
at the table differently than
if they seemed less wealthy.
And she has limits
on her-- she knows,
she's really quite
remarkable, she
knows the limits of
her mental models.
She knows that a lot
of her mental models
work in the United States,
but if she's playing overseas
in London, and if she's got
foreigners at the table,
her models won't work
well enough for her
to use in guiding
the way she gambles.
So that's a very different
kind of personal intelligence
than Katharine Graham used,
but it's personal intelligence
nonetheless.
It's a very utilitarian
personal intelligence,
that she uses for those
moments when she's gambling.
And I assume, I
didn't ask her, I'm
sure she uses personal
intelligence in other areas
of her life as well,
maybe more broadly,
when she's deciding
to get married
or whatever, she's
going to evaluate
her partner a lot
differently than that.
So, had I my slides here,
I would invite you all
to take a test of personal
intelligence with me,
but I don't have
them here, so I can
invite you to go online, to
personalintelligence.info,
personalintelligence, all one
word, dot info, or of course
you could just Google
it, and it would,
and it actually comes up first.
And on the banner
navigation bar, is the quiz.
And so after this
lecture if you like,
you can take the quiz
if you're interested.
I will say a few
things about the quiz.
Our tests are about
140 items in length,
because we're serious
about our measurement,
we want to give people
accurate feedback.
You cannot give people accurate
feedback by either asking
people, oh how good is
your personal intelligence?
Because everybody's
above average.
On average, people
are above average.
And so we set them
problems to do.
But anybody here,
how long did you
stay in school to
get a job at Google?
Some number of years, right?
Some number of years.
You do not learn
an area quickly,
and it is not possible
to measure your aptitude
in an area quickly either.
Which is why the SATs
are four hours long,
and our test has to be-- well
we're measuring one sub area,
our test is about 40
to 45 minutes long.
So when you do
that quiz, it just
shows you how the test works.
It doesn't really give you much
of an answer, because as I say,
those items are too short to do.
So to sum up, I think
that personal intelligence
is really important, because it
tells us the logic that people
use when they reason
about personality.
I'm kind of a lazy person
in certain respects,
and all those people giving
me advice throughout my life
is difficult for me, because
it's a lot of different things
to remember, and I
do notice that there
are repetitions that run through
them, which help me remember,
kind of like, follow what
you're interested in, one which
is very high in
personal intelligence,
but I really don't
like is, I can't answer
that question for you, you
need to make up your own mind.
I hate that, like when I'm
asking what should I do,
and people say, well
that's really up to you,
like, go, go away.
But that's got high
personal intelligence,
because the answer is, I mean we
have to guide our own choices,
only we know how we are inside.
And so, I'm very
excited that we've
uncovered this new
area of reasoning,
and I think also it has to
come back to that robot issue,
it has applications
in engineering
as well, soon after
Peter and I came out
with emotional
intelligence, I don't
think I'm remembering
her first name correctly,
but I think her last
name is Breazeal, at MIT,
created Kismet,
a robot who could
perceive emotions
and express emotions.
And I noticed in the front
page of the Wall Street Journal
today, there's an article
about how at Carnegie Mellon,
there's a person
there who's developed
a robot that or rather
artificial, an expert
system that plays Scrabble,
and the expert system
has the advantage of making
rude comments to other players
while playing, so as to gain
some kind of an advantage,
and to cover up, actually,
for its less than superb
Scrabble playing skills.
So I think probably as we
understand personality more,
and we start deciphering
the exact rules, which
is to me the most exciting part
of understanding personality
that people employ,
that may have
some practical
applications as well.
So I want to thank
you very much,
and I'm very open to questions.
Yes please.
AUDIENCE: This is a
really great topic,
so thank you so much for
coming here and talking to us.
I've got two quick
questions, so you
know when you talk about
personality, a lot of people
say how malleable
is personality?
Surrounding like, time,
situation, and your need
to change, you have to adapt
to different situations,
are you changing your
core personality?
What are your thoughts on that?
And then a follow
up question is,
do people with higher
emotional personal intelligence
have a higher degree
of self awareness?
If they are able to see
maybe others clearly,
do they see themselves
more clearly?
Or is there no correlation?
JOHN MAYER: OK.
So the first
question, and this is
going to require
some concentration,
so if I forget the
second question
I may come back to you.
But the first question is how
much can personality change?
And I believe
personality can change,
I think I've changed
my own personality,
I think I've watched
other people change.
A few years ago I had braces,
because I had braces as a kid,
but my teeth didn't,
it didn't take,
my teeth got crooked again,
so I had to have braces again.
It took like three or four
years to get my teeth straight
the second time, and I
think with personality,
one of the issues
if it's something
core about your
personality, it may
take a few years to guide
yourself into a new place,
but I do think it's
quite possible to do.
Your second question was--
Self awareness, right.
Yes, I think that
people are-- I think
people have an enormous
advantage if they are higher
in personal
intelligence, in becoming
self aware for a couple reasons.
First of all, I
mentioned in 2007,
I was working on several papers
that didn't work well together.
The reason was, one was
actually on self understanding,
and the other was on
understanding personality.
And I realized in the midst
of that, oh, you know,
you can't do one
without the other.
Like, if I don't know the
difference between somebody
who's an introvert, who
likes to spend time alone,
and somebody who's shy, who
might prefer to spend more
time with other people,
but is anxious doing so,
how am I ever going to use
those labels accurately
as applying them to myself.
So that's one advantage, is
that, we have to understand
personality in general,
which is why I call
it personal
intelligence, in part,
we have to understand
it in general
to apply it either to
ourselves or to others.
But the other, as I was writing
the book, another thing that
really, surprised
me, because I thought
I was sort of done with
the theory, but in the book
I learned all kinds
of new things.
And very instructed
by the people
whose examples are there.
If you're defensive, sorry--
if you're low in personal
intelligence, you don't know who
to trust and who not to trust,
and who is accurate about
personality, and who isn't.
So you are in a position
of not being able--
and people say all kinds
of things about us, right?
And some of it's true
sometimes, and some of it
isn't at all true.
And so one of the hard
things about taking criticism
and feedback, is you have to
sit there, and of course nobody
likes criticism and
feedback, and you
have to sit there and go,
oh darn it, is that right?
Could I be a
controlling bastard?
Or whatever.
Could that apply to me?
And we think about
that for a while,
and we go, you know, I think
there might be a germ of truth
in that, because I can see it
in this spot, and that spot,
and the other spot,
and plus somebody else
said that to me once too.
But if you're low in
personal intelligence,
you hear that and you
go, well I don't know,
that could be as
much off the wall
as what that person
said to me yesterday,
I don't know whether
it's true or not.
So I'm not going to
take it seriously.
And you're in that
existential position
of not knowing whose
advice, whose feedback
is accurate or not.
Because sometimes
people say things to us
that are completely wrong.
And we have to be able
to know which is right,
and we have to be able
to know on reflection,
and thinking about it, which
is right and which is wrong.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JOHN MAYER: Yes,
please, Matthew, right?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned sort
of practical applications
and things like artificial
intelligence systems
and [INAUDIBLE],
and you did tell us
where we can go and take
the test, I'm wondering,
it almost sounds like you be
better having everyone else's
test answers walking into the
room, so that you can apply
that out, what are
the like, lower level
first steps of personal
application of getting
the results of the test.
JOHN MAYER: Sorry, can you
clarify just a little bit more?
AUDIENCE: I guess I'm wondering
like, if you go and you find
out that you have
a certain skill set
in this personal
intelligence, how can you
apply that back onto yourself
to change parts of your day
to day life that you might
want to tweak or improve.
JOHN MAYER: OK.
So I think one way to look at
that question is, how can we
learn more, how can we gain more
knowledge about personality so
as to be able to
reason with it better.
And my first line of
defense, I realize
it sounds self serving, in
answering that question,
is to say, take a look at the
book, because that's actually,
that's one of my joys
in working on the book,
was to be able to look
at a lot of people who
are high in personal
intelligence,
and think about those people as
role models for how to do it.
Now ultimately, I'd like
to see there be curricula
that teach us about personality.
But the other way that
I hear your question
is asking, if there's a
part of my personality
that I want to tweak, how
do I go about doing that?
And I think that the steps
involved in that are probably
first, are you sure
you want to change it,
because it is time consuming,
like when I got my braces,
my dentist and some other
dentist, the orthodontist,
were having a debate as to
whether I should have braces.
And I think, start that debate.
You can ask people who
you trust and know,
hey if I changed in
such and such a way,
would that make me a
better person, or would
you like, relate to me
better, if I were that way,
and if they say yes, then I
think the change process itself
is a matter of self coaxing, and
having very low expectations,
and realizing that
you're going to fail--
and I'm saying this out
of personal experience.
When I try to change
something in myself.
OK, it's not going to be
tomorrow, it's going to be,
I'm going to try this out
for a year very gently,
month after month, and I'm going
to backslide, but kind of lean
it that way.
Does that help at all?
How about one, two, and three?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN MAYER: Well
intelligence, researchers
think of intelligence
as an aptitude.
But I think it's possible
to improve your functioning
with whatever personal
intelligence you have.
And I like to draw the
analogy of most of us,
no matter how good or
bad at math we are,
we usually use textbooks
to teach us about math.
So same way with
personality, it doesn't
matter, as long as we
have a reasonable amount
of personal intelligence,
we can learn
some amount of, if you will,
personal intelligence algebra,
from the experts.
There are few exceptions
sorry, it just
comes to mind, I can't
help-- John Stuart Mill, who
had a recorded IQ of 210,
reports from his tutors were,
that it would be
easier for him to solve
the problem mathematically
and derive the formula,
rather than look
it up in the book.
So it said that he was
able to solve most math
problems without
reference to the book.
But most of us
refer to the book.
And so-- whatever
book that may be,
and so I think that's
the better way to do it.
Now, did I miss a
part of your question?
No, OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: From a
marketing perspective
in your book, [INAUDIBLE] you
want to measure something,
you usually want to measure
something to improve it.
So you talked about the
Stanford professor who
has the high spatial
intelligence ability,
and you alluded to having some
of these examples in your book,
could it be some of these
emotional intelligence heroes
are people that we would
look up to, and want
to be like, and therefore want
to take this quiz so that we
can improve ourselves,
and be like them?
JOHN MAYER: Well first,
your premise, if I may.
There are intelligences that
I'm not particularly good at,
and I just go, OK.
There are a lot of
broad intelligences,
I don't got 'em all,
I don't have them all,
and that's all right with me.
So one of the points I
try to make in the book
is that, you can do
this as a voyeur,
without necessarily
needing to go there.
But if you were interested
in that, some of the people
who, there are a lot of
different people, some
of the public figures that
I talk about are people
like Oprah Winfrey, gosh,
who is the Michael Jordan,
a all the people are, hang
on, I have them on a slide.
Yeah, Katharine Graham, Oprah
Winfrey, Michael Jordan,
David Carr of the New York
Times, Sydney Blatt of Yale
University, and
research participants
in dozens of
ingenious experiments.
That's a short list of some
of the people who are there.
Other questions?
Yes, oh right, sorry.
AUDIENCE: So with
emotional intelligence,
I think there are like
four key pro tips right?
So you got the self
awareness, I think
it's situational awareness, I
can't think of the third one,
and then it's like,
relationship management?
JOHN MAYER: Yeah, that's
the journalistic account,
that's not our four.
That's not the four that Peter
and David and I work with,
but that's OK, I can go
there with you, so go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So would
you say that the four
concepts of personal
intelligence map in parallel,
or is it more so mapped
to one in particular?
JOHN MAYER: Well these four
are different than either-- I
think the issue with
the broadened emotional
intelligence model, is
that model emphasizes
having a certain personality.
And that personality is good
social relationships, optimism,
persistence, zeal, you probably
know them better than I do.
But there's a long
list of qualities
you're supposed
to develop, right?
I think that's wrong.
I think you can have, and
we know from our research,
that people of all
different personalities
can be high or low in
personal intelligence.
And in fact, the
personality that you
want to develop-- well
first of all, some of it,
it's set to some degree, I
mean we have some genetics
and learning, you know, 10,
20, 30 years of background
that's formed our
personality as it is.
So I'm more of a kind of-- to
go back to the poker analogy,
you've got your hand, what's
the best way to play it,
kind of person.
How can I be the most high
functioning pessimist ever?
How can I be completely
oblivious to social cues,
but still have people
like me, and respect me,
and want me to be around.
So I think that's more of
the personal intelligence
model I'm talking about.
Any other questions?
Thank you very much.
Thanks, thanks very
much for coming.